I told you there's a travel advisory for
Mexico yeah I know
freaked me out but they're only killing
each other you know what I'm saying but
for now yeah occasionally they did go
dark but I look Mexican so I'm like oh
maybe they keep you first
well they kidnapped me I'm like a sex
slave oh there's like mr. Schwaab we
want to talk to you
we love Mexico we will have Mexicans but
they're too short so we brought you in
to be a sex slave we're going to
impregnate to all these beautiful women
with your perfect DNA yeah I'm just like
a stud horse exactly just slinging back
out there you're just getting [ __ ] in a
slingshot
I think I'm being tortured but it's
awesome just we have this new thing it's
a mixture of zinc magnesium and steroid
loads just building up in your balls but
I gotta make videos like being mad at
America and chompin [ __ ] but you guys
can tell I'm happiest [ __ ] I'm Jack from
all the steroids say this wall is [ __ ]
up and it's the reason why I'm stuck
[Laughter]
[ __ ] SEAL Team six boys please please
stick around for what